[Applause]
hi everybody hello
thanks guys i really appreciate it i'm
so
lucky i get to be with the vff and our
crew
who has so much energy thank you we
carry
each other it's amazing and you know
what because
we're all family people here and we talk
about our families is there any moms in
our vffs today
how are you we are so excited to see you
i'm so excited to see you too and i
understand that it is someone's birthday
today
it is on her 17th birthday is
incredible i
saw you guys in the wall and i wanted to
say hello
only to find out that connor's birthday
is today
and he is so excited he just loves you
and you make him smile
every day oh my gosh oh
connor well connor i now that i found
out that it's your birthday
i'm gonna figure out what to get for you
and by the end of the show i am going to
tell you
but kelly i found out a little intel
about you
as a mom you're a worker outer right
yes uh i am a runner and uh we have
purchased a peloton so we have been
enjoying the bike
we are celebrating moms today we're
obviously going to celebrate connor's
birthday
through the whole show and make sure
that he has some
awesome present that i'm going to
contemplate the entire show and
uh but can i celebrate you being a mom
today um i have been interested in
trying the mirror
it's all the rage it's like
the future basically and i'm going to
send you one
if that's okay oh my gosh
yes thank you
[Applause]
oh happy birthday connor i'll get back
to you guys with a surprise
in a little bit i want to be thoughtful
about this so we wanted to donate
5 000 to the children's cranio facial
association
on your behalf and put it up on our
website
and call attention to it and see if we
can get everyone to contribute and just
honor connor on his birthday thank you
thank you connor and kelly and
please let me know if there's anything
else we can ever do
we'd love to see you again come on the
show
and keep in touch thank you drew we will
thank you connor and kelly happiest of
birthdays to you
it is such a pleasure and a privilege to
know you both
and we'll be checking back in with you
thank you so much
vff's for hanging out with us today to
all the moms
out there just
if i rip out my heart and i give it to
you is that creepy well
it's what i want to do so thank you
everyone
who comes here hangs out with us works
here
visits in the wall and watches thank you
have a wonderful rest of your day
you